hello everyone
and welcome to today's webinar
understanding the in vitro diagnostic
regulation
everything you need to know i am
michelle ashton of lab roots and i'll be
your moderator for today's event today's
educational web seminar is presented by
labyrinth
and brought to you by molecular
diagnostic at abbott
to learn more visit abbott.com let's get
started
before we begin i would like to remind
everyone that this event
is interactive we encourage you to
participate
by submitting as many questions as you
want and any time you want during the
presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box
and click send we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for
at the end of the presentation if you
have trouble
seeing or hearing the presentation
please click on the support tab
found at the top right of the
presentation window
or report your problem by clicking on
the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
this presentation
is educational and thus offers
continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab
located at the top right of the
presentation window
and follow the process to obtain your
credits
i now present today's speaker dr petra
cars
villa the independent consultant for a
complete biography on our seeker
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen
petra you may now begin your
presentation welcome
thank you very much michelle for the
introduction
welcome to our introduction to the new
ivd medical device regulation
today i'm talking about the most
significant
uh change in legislation for ivds within
the last
20 years
so we will have on the agenda
three topics i will give you a brief
background
and the main aspects to the current
legislation
we will then speak about the new
ivd regulation and the major changes
and i will share with you
what's in the regulation for diagnostic
world tours
um let's start with a with a definition
um the in vitro diagnostic medical
device
is a reagent or reagent product
calibrator
control material kit instrument
apparatus or equipment software or
system which is used alone or in
combination
to provide information on
physiological and pathological state on
physical
or mental impairments concerning the
preposition
to a medical condition or disease on the
safety and compatibility with
potential recipients to predict
treatment response or reactions
to define or monitor therapeutic
measures
well this definition is exactly the same
also under the new regulation so it has
nothing being changed
with a small
minor item and this is that software now
is also being integrated in this
definition
um so standalone software
is also now being defined under ivd
medical devices
um sorry for that but i have to go
through a couple of more definitions
um first of all and and for sure you
know you will hear a little more about
this uh the ivd directive itself
[Music]
the member state
under the ivd directors the national
member states in europe they are free
to decide how to transpose
directive international laws
[Music]
this basically you know sets then the
framework for manufacturers
and for authorized representatives if
they want you know to
place their products on the eu market
um the ivd regulation which is the new
regulation
uh which is the topic of today um
has a binding legal force throughout
every uh eu member state
um and it has a five
year transition time and this ends
may 27 2022
it utilized the framework established
from the directive with additional
requirements
for manufacturers to place
ibds on the market
i felt it may be interesting you know to
also come up with two more definitions
especially because those are quite often
being mixed up
and there's one you know this is the
certification
it's it's a formal attestation or a
confirmation
of a quality management system um
and this is uh according the iso
standards or products
then it's a notified body certification
and it's design examination
certification this is
another term you know which is being
used
while accreditation is a process in
which certifications of
competency authority or credibility is
presented
examples are like the notified body are
being accredited against
the ibd regulation or the medical device
regulation
while laboratories are accredited
against
iso 151889
or 17 or 25.
so certification is the certification
for processes or products
while accreditation concentrates
on the competency the authority and the
credibility of the personnel
in laboratories or working for notified
bodies
i have to come up with a little bit of
history
um the european union
started to harmonize medical devices
in the end of the 90s
in the so-called new approach directors
the key element was to have a framework
for all
ivd medical devices
but only few high-risk products were
assessed
by an assessment body which is the
notified body
all other were assessed under the
responsibility of the manufacturer
its purpose was to ensure that the
devices
would be regulated in a proportionate
manner while maintaining a high level of
product safety
and the aim was also to minimize any
unnecessary bureaucratic burden
imposed on manufacturers
it was also based on the relation
realization
that it would be pretty expensive to
impose
identical regulatory controls on all
medical devices
irrespective of the risk involved
one other key element was the free
movement of goods between the member
states
and the ce mark basically is uh
i would i would call it the european
passport
um so that the goods could have be could
be
moved within europe but on the other
hand also
uh be freely being imported into the
european
market
the essential requirements
from the in vitro diagnostic
directors
are being introduced
[Music]
to regulate the safety
the product safety the performance
of ivds
and the
[Music]
the reason for sure was you know patient
safety
the manufacturer they have to to
demonstrate
compliance with those requirements
before placing the products to the
market
and they also had to decide you know
which
requirements are essential for their
products
[Music]
there were other elements which were
introduced
with this directive was
the establishment of a risk management
a systematic medical event reporting
as well as the introduction of common
technical specification for high-risk
products
so it was the first time that across
europe
the same specification applied
for example for hepatitis and hiv
products and so the manufacturer knew
how many samples have to be tested and
what are the minimum criteria for
example
for the sensitivity or the specificity
and that helped also to increase
the performance of the products
at that time
um another introduction
was to use notified bodies these are
independent organizations independent
from
the competent health authorities
in the countries a notified body has
is accredited by an authorized equitable
accrediting body that could be being
part of the national
health authorities
and a notified body had to be
designated by a member state
um that what they do is they
assess the conformity so they
check you know the product performance
and and how the product is being
designed and made
according the essential requirements
they are also entitled to perform
on-site inspections as well as
entitled to examine a product
as well as watching for example the
manufacturing process
nx2 products these are the high risk
products
listed under nx2 of the director
they were being spelled out
and those require a special
certification by
a third party called notified body
a declaration of conformity is
required for every single product
as well as the notified body
is being listed in a database
and it's called the nundo information
system too
where everyone also can
look up if the notified body is being
accredited
and by whom
the notified body as i said before
is not needed for every product under
the directive
there are basically three groups of
products one is the so called
nx2 list a
these are that like the blood and blood
donor
screening assays or other hepatitis and
hiv assays blood grouping tests
those require an assessment by a
notified body
the annex ii list b products are mainly
the so-called torch essays toxoplasmosis
rubella
pseudomegalovirus psa
is a screening marker as well as
self-test
for glucose monitoring
and the third group where notified body
is being required are the lay use
products such as pregnancy tests for
example the notified body especially for
those essays would look into the design
whether the design is appropriate for
lay use
as well as the labeling
if this is also being
appropriate for a lay user for
all other products the manufacturer is
self
declaring the product um
as being in conformity with the
directive
now i'm going to tell you more about the
ivd regulation
and
first of all you wonder you know why
a new regulation was required
um the
in 98 the directive has been laid down
the way you know that as i said
uh initially that the member states
have to take the tax and have to put
this
into their national law so this
gave the member states a lot of freedom
uh how to phrase your the the
the the new legislation um
so we had a lot of variation variations
um in also the interpretation
of the directive
a regulation now is the most direct
form of an eu law it's binding
and it's free from adaptation within the
individual
member states it's being translated in
the national
languages present
in the eu but it's a direct
translation so there is they cannot the
member states cannot change the wording
in any way um and
it's still the compliance is still
required for medical devices as well as
for ibd medical devices for the ce
marking requirements
uh there has been basically uh
they have been in the framework there
have been no
major changes um
and and and still this
e-marking is required to place and
uh maintain the product on the eu market
as well as you know we see more and more
other markets who rely on the cmark
and and trust the
eu for the because of the framework
to see the the complexity
going from the directive to the
regulation
you can also see that the ibd directive
has been
only 35 pages and the ibd regulation
now has 157 pages
so this gives room for
many more
requirements but also it has been
much better laid out um
what the requirements are so that there
is a
much better interpretation
[Music]
there is there are other reasons why
the ivd regulation have been
put into place especially
because there have been issues in the
market
it's it's a response to historical
product failures
or failures in the responsibility within
the eu
whether these are notified bodies or
competent authorities
and the
notified bodies uncovered issues with
manufacturers
they have been inadequate or partially
updated technical files
limited clinical evaluation have been
done
they have been an incomplete post-market
surveillance system in place or
incomplete or no
post-market clinical follow-up had been
done
or inconsistent reviews or use by dates
and limited work on usability or
economics
superficial risk management is another
example
on the other hand competent authorities
and the commission
uncovered issues with notified bodies
and maybe you remember
there have been this scandal in france
with the company pip where they used
industry silicon
for breast implants
and the notified body was not able to
detect this during inspections
[Music]
there have been areas for improvement
being
identified like the transparency
traceability and
accountability so it was not possible
to say which products are on the market
it was very hard to find out
[Music]
and for sure it was even harder to find
out for
users or patients
and there was also a need of greater
involvement of users
and patients
[Music]
the regulation
aims to ensure that
ivds meet the highest standard of
product safety and efficacy
through the entire product lifecycle
[Music]
that is not new that was always
the goal for these regulations
as i said before the issues with the
directive
that there have been too many
differences in the national
transpositions
different interpretations different
rules
many databases diverse requirements and
different countries
so we hope that the regulation
will be able you know to reduce you know
many of these
of these issues
there's also a demand interesting enough
from other non-eu countries for more
centralized controls
because for products which are
not being assessed
by an official authority
other authorities may not trust in this
so there is none or low acceptance
for european products self-declared by
manufacturers
on the other hand the new regulation
is also shooting for better
harmonization to worldwide requirements
on the other hand the revision was due
after 15 years the medical device
directive was due after 15 years and
the ivd regulation much younger
but they still being put
on the to-do list for
a vision
yeah the timeline as i said
five years the ivd regulation had
been published in may 2017
so the transition ends
may 27th 2022
or and actually it ends
may 26 2022 and
the ibdr enforcement will begin
may 27 2022
if the product is already in the
distribution chain
it's in the warehouse of the
distributors
it's in the refrigerators of the
laboratories
it can still be used
until may 27 2025
unless the
existing ivd directive
certificate expires and for the
high-risk products the latest date for
that
is may 26 2024
um and well and also the shelf life of
the product has to be
taken care of and
but the ultimate date for using it up
would be
may 27 2025
um we want to look um at the
main changes um
one is the
harmonization as i said before not just
the same approach among member states
but also
with with global regulations
transparency there will be
one european database
and this database there will be access
for the public access for
everyone um and
uh you can look up you know who's
legally
responsible for the product who is
legally on the market
the performance data are there any
recalls or major events for that product
and so it will be a
much better way
also for every stakeholder
to understand you know the the the
markets
um liability um is
one item which has been also
focused on it it has never been
mentioned before but there are other
regulations
covering this in europe
but here the ibd regulation discusses
liability
with a focus because they want to be
sure
that the companies do have the resources
um in in a major event
or recalls uh that was never been an
issue for bigger companies
but for smaller or mid-sized companies
that has been an issue in the past and
so the companies you know have to
put the focus on this put resources
aside
or setting up
assurance contracts
[Music]
evidence the clinical evidence is a new
term
as well as scientific validities another
term
which is being newly introduced
products have to be
better defined the intended uses have to
be better defined
and there must be exactly according to
medical needs
and this may also require
clinical more clinical performance
testing before
the these products assessed under the
directive can go
or stay on the market under the ivd
regulation
post market surveillance is another area
which has been introduced before
but under the regulation
now it became
a huge item because
first of all it's a more systematic
post-market plan is required the report
is required
as well as there are special audits
by the notified body on that
area trend reporting by manufacturers
have to be done to the competent
authorities
and we will see probably
many more post-market
studies the manufacturers is required
to watch the performance
of the assets in the market
[Music]
over the whole shelf life
so that will be also a major cost
driver for the manufacturers
yeah more scrutiny
[Music]
as i said before there are
under the directives there were were
only
maybe 10 to 20 percent uh
under a notified body but now we will
probably see 80 to
90 percent of all products have to go
through a notified body assessment and
that's that's another cost driver for
manufacturers
um a novel
product and high-risk products um
they have to undergo a so-called
scrutiny process
because they have to go through
an assessment through an expert group
from the eu so that there is an
expert group being set up for medical
devices and ivd medical devices
and after the nullified body has
assessed the product
this expert group you know has to look
at these products once more
before it can be introduced to the
product
to the market sorry
classification um has
been changed um and that
is has been done also um
due to the fact that there is a
better harmonization with
global regulations
and under the under the
ibd regulation we will have the new
classification is
from the lowest class class a to the
highest class
class d class d
covers all the hepatitis
or hiv blood donor screening assays
but also hiv blood diagnostic
tests [ __ ] blood grouping
see covers a lot of infectious diseases
prenatal screening
blood glucose monitoring
especially also for for lay users
psa screening hla typing
class b is a kind of it's called
the default group so everything which
does not fall into d
and c is b uh
except a couple of class a products
um so you will find a lot of products
under class b all clinical chemistry
pregnancy self-testing urine test straps
cholesterol self-testing
a lot of hormones are being in class
b class a
is a smaller group with like wash
buffers
culture media specimen receptacles
but also the analyzers are being covered
under class a
and they are in the lowest class because
they are being assessed
anyway you know with all the essays
under the specific class so that's why
it's fine putting the analyzers itself
into the lowest class
the new term clinical evidence has been
introduced with the ibd regulation
this was also due to the fact of global
harmonization
so that everyone in the world
of ivd medical devices are using the
same
terms like clinical evidence
and scientific validity
those are the terms you know we would
use in
in future to cover clinical evidence
there are
basically three
groups there's the analytical
performance
um then the scientific validity
[Music]
and then the clinical performance they
all three make
up to the clinical evidence
[Music]
the um the
manufacturers they have to have
reports on everything and then finally
when they have um finalized
the analytical performance report to the
scientific validity
and the proof of the
needs of the product
in the medical world
and then also the clinical performance
report this all comes together
and the clinical evidence report is is
being
written this has to be done for every
single product which
is currently in the market
independently whether the product has
been introduced most recently
or 10 years ago it has to be done for
every single product so that's a
major effort for the companies
and and
we will see you know how much this will
drive
uh quality for sure you know
when they have this probably the only
one you know which may
drive quality um the
the requirements
also you know other intended users are
being correct are there data
for everything all of this has to be
checked
once more and the notified body
will assess this as well um
the major the most i mean for products
which have been 20 years in the market
and they have been validated so many
times and they are very well established
we will see probably not much difference
on the other hand new biomarkers for
example or genetics
tests maybe we will
see that there are more additional
studies
being required
the risk classification impact um
the the major impact is
that many products require now
a notified body involvement before they
can
stay on the market or being newly
introduced into the market
so the regulation
[Music]
requires um now probably about 80 to 90
percent
uh of all products um
being under notified body um
and 10 to 20 um
will not require a notified body it
depends a little bit on the mix
of uh for for company to company there
is a different mix of products but
while the past many manufacturers
have not been uh involved in
working with the notified body and
now they have to set up the contract i
mean they have to decide
and i have to to set up the contract and
so on
[Music]
and on the other hand
the eu commission
wants to reduce the number of notified
bodies
so currently we have
five notified bodies being assessed or
accredited
by the authorities before
we had around
[Music]
20 30 notified bodies so therefore
we will see a lot of uncertainty over
the next couple of
months who will be accredited
are the contracts being set up will the
companies be ready
by the time the
regulation kicks in
yeah what are the the major uh trends
um uh there are
uh there's a regulatory impact
so i i think i just uh
explained this a little bit with the
minority of companies having to interact
with the notified body for the first
time
[Music]
that many of them now you know to
to work with with
such an assessment body um
[Music]
the market impact
bigger companies probably better
prepared may leave
smaller companies behind
investment and or divestment
opportunities to rise
[Music]
for sure the time to market for all
classes of products
is expected to increase
so for new products um that
will take much more time to to get a
product to market
[Music]
the the third impact the product impact
we will very likely see in the market
[Music]
that there is a change in the
product portfolio
[Music]
the
strategic review of the portfolio would
need to happen when the
cost of keeping a typically older
product on the market
outweighed the commercial benefit
so companies may
[Music]
reduce their portfolio potentially
uncertainty yeah i talked about this a
little bit
that how we are moving forward with
with less notified bodies
and there had been also due to brexit
there have been also the
reduction a couple of
british notified bodies are not
there anymore so there have been some
changes and i talked about cost
and pricing um the companies expect the
manufacturing costs to rise
and there are several areas i mentioned
this before
this additional testing requirements
notified body costs
competent authority costs as well
through the database
so but not i think no one knows exactly
you know what the cause will be right
now so
that is another aspect of uncertainty
yeah what does it mean the ivt
regulation
for diagnostic laboratories
[Music]
the laboratory developed tests i think
it's a term
we use
[Music]
is very very common
but it's not being mentioned in the
regulation
in the regulation we speak about
in-house developed tests
and the ivdr
commits laboratories to use commercial
devices instead of in-house developed
tests
when available
[Music]
so the same standard applies
and substantially the same efforts to
the development of
in-house developed tests very much like
a regular ivd manufacturer
and even subject to the ltds to a full
conformity assessment procedure
including a notified body depending on
the class so for
a higher class as we said class c and d
um the and
and many bees are
affected by this
uh regulations applied to software as i
said before
so open source software that's that is
used in several institutions
maybe an ivd device on its own right so
this has to be assessed to ensure that
there is no conflict
with the regulation
yeah the ldt's in the area of ivdr
the the ivdr prefaces the
regulation of ldt's with the statement
health institutions should have the
possibility of manufacturing modifying
and using devices in-house and thereby
addressing on a non-industrial scale
the specific needs of target
patient groups which cannot be met at
the appropriate level of performance
by an equivalent device available on the
market
so the eu commission accepts
that health institutions um
are manufacturing um or using these
ldt's
um but on the other hand
um they they're the first thing you know
they should always look
for what is available in the market
and the standards you know should be
the same but also demonstrates
to be well aware of the possible risks
to ensure the highest level of health
protection the rules
governing individual diagnostic medical
devices manufactured and used within a
single health institution
only should be clarified and
strengthened
the news should be understood to include
measurement
and delivery of results
so
therefore the limits the
ability to bank products in-house by
declaring the health institution should
have
the possibility of manufacturing devices
in-house which cannot be met at the
appropriate level of performance
by an equivalent device available on the
market
so the ivd-r stresses this
again and again that
in-house manufactured tests should be
only used
if there's no equivalent available on
the market
therefore the laboratories um
using such such ld leds
must justify in writing
[Music]
that there is that there is no
alternative
basically um and
if the justification is caused
then it's not a good idea because it
does not represent sufficient
justification
monitoring both the performance of the
test and the clinical justification for
its use
and then maintaining the documentation
about the manufacturing and the use of
the tests
and is certain if the national
competent authorities may require design
manufacturing performance data so
they can request that technical
documentation is being submitted
if an institution decides to continue
to make their own ldt's
they have to have an expectation
according
en iso 15189
and to demonstrate the competency
authority or credibility
of their testing capabilities
on the other hand they have to establish
a quality management system and they
have to follow
iso 13485
they must not transfer the device to
another legal entity so they
can only use the device within their own
health institution
and they have to draw up a declaration
that the safety and performance
requirements of annex
1 of the ivd regulation are fulfilled
and as i said before you know for class
d
devices for example the full technical
documentation has to be written up
and must be ready for review by the
competent authority
another term which is used uh
research use only
sometimes it's interesting it's also
mixed up with with ldt's
but also research use only is not being
mentioned
in the ivd regulation
but a research use only product is a
product that is labeled for
testing for the initial research phase
of product development
including but not limited to test kit
methods component analyzed to be
measured
laboratory research unrelated to product
development so it cannot be used for
medical purpose
it has no intended use it cannot carry a
cemuck
and is not used and allowed to be used
in diagnostic
procedures the research use only product
would not fall
under the ivd regulation
but the requirements
as mentioned before they must strictly
be followed
to ensure that it's not in conflict with
the ivd regulation
how can i see that the product is being
compliant can i see this on the labeling
yeah there are some indications
[Music]
if first of all the product has to be ce
marked
[Music]
before and after the deadline
a notified body number is being added
you will see a unique device
identification number
is being added a barcode and a human
readable format
but you may have seen that before
because also other countries are
requesting this
um and you can check
[Music]
in the nando database
whether the notified body is being
on the list and is
it and the notified body is being
accredited by the appropriate
national eu member state
there's another way to to look for
compliance
uh these are the certificates of
conformity
and there are a number uh
for self-declaration uh i'm the
manufacturer has to
write
a document up and it has to relate
to the new ivd regulation
a 2017 746
ec the new classification has to be
added
whether it's class d c b or a
and the certificates are from conformity
from the notified body so many many
products as we said probably
80 of all ivds
have to
also relate to the new uh ivd regulation
2017 746 ec
that is the uh more obvious
uh thing to see how
uh whether the product is being
compliant
um the other way is you know to
ask the ivd company
about the products here are some of the
questions you may want
to ask and ivd company must be able to
answer
what is your plan to become compliant
with the ibd
device regulation what's your plan to
become compliant with the uei
requirements
who is your notified body
what is the notified body number can you
provide a draft of your due declaration
of conformity
maybe some products are already being
assessed but only few because there are
so many many more things to be done from
the eu commission side
um can you provide a list of the
products we buy from you within your
product classes
this will be good for yourself also to
familiarize with the with the new
product classes
and what are your changes uh to labeling
beside labeling and the certificates
for laboratories it is important
especially for the incoming
quality control to check you know that
the documents and the labeling is being
in compliance
yeah by may 2022
and this is less than two years from now
all existing products uh
have to be uh reassessed
and they have brought have to be brought
into compliance
or have to be removed from the market so
it's a it's a lot of work which
needs to be done within the short period
of time
yeah in summary the ivd-r represents
an enormous change to the industry
not only because it requires a
significant change
to technical documentation and the
quality management system
but also because it changes the
relationship
with economic operators with
distributors with
authorized representatives with
importers
and their responsibility manufacturers
have often
launched in europe before the u.s
however under the ivdr the requirements
are more onerous and will take more time
for approval to be completed and this
may
change the way products are launched in
the future
while there is undoubtedly a huge amount
of work
required to transition from the ivdd to
the
regulation manufacturers should
recognize
the ivdr is more complex and detailed
and
will require more resources to maintain
as well as implement so another cost
driver
are the resources finally it's important
to anticipate
change many guidance documents have not
been published
and further implementation and
delegating acts
are yet to be published which will
change expectations
and lead to rework of the documentation
and quality management system the ibdr
is very much in its infancy
and all state holders need to be
prepared for its evolution
over the coming years this gets me to
the end
thank you very much for listening
and i will be very happy to take
questions
thank you petra for your informative
presentations
we will now start the q a portion of the
webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now just click on the ask a
question box
located on the far left of your screen
and we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for
okay let's go ahead and get started
your first question is what should i
check to be sure my lab is ready for the
ivdr
our lab is accredited and so all methods
have been validated
it's also iso certified and have
standard operating procedures
is this sufficient to consider our
institution
ivdr compliance
yeah to answer the the first part of the
question
you should make sure that you use
ivds which are ce marked
and devices for
all diagnostic procedures you perform in
your lab
and to do so
you have to ensure that
for products purchased from
manufacturers to receive
formal assurance that they are ivd
regulation
compliant maybe even randomly checking
one of them
towards the regulation for ldt's
and research use only
a product be sure that there is no ce
marked product available in the market
and that all requirements have been
covered
follow the text of the the ibd
regulation
that's the easiest way to tick
to tick the boxes and to answer
the second part of the question
the answer is no being iso certified or
accredited
this is not sufficient to the ibdr
compliance the compliance introduced by
the new regulation is related to the
products not to the lab using them
okay thank you your next question
i use ce marked ibd probes
probes which are validated in my lab
with the new regulation implemented
should i re-validate my existing fish
protocol
well you need to to work closely with
your manufacturer to understand
if a revalidation is needed because
the ibd company who has ce marked
the probes is required to ensure that
the probes are compliant
with the latest regulation so the
revalidation will be needed if any
change has been made to the product
to make the to make the product
ivdr compliant
okay now what should i do
if there are no ceivd products
available and i have been using
validated ru reagents for the testing so
far
so if there are no ce marked ivd
products available you can continue
using your resource research use only
reagent
or also an ldt
but you have to follow the requirements
of the ibd regulation
[Music]
as stated before and
that requires you an extensive
documentation and maybe even
submission to the competent authority
thank you petra we have time for a
couple more questions
your next question is if my lab is not
ivdr compliant by may 2022 is
there a risk it will be closed or
excluded from diagnostic testing
the decision is with your local
authority because
they are
doing the surveillance and
they may come to your lap and audit you
uh for compliance
um many of the authorities are aware
that labs are using
ldt's or research use only um
and i'm sure they have a band of
possible punishment from paying a fine
to closing the lab
so it depends on the seriousness
okay great thank you we have time for
one more question
will the existing ceivd labels be valid
after may 2022
most likely no there are there are too
many
changes required by the new um ivd
regulation as i said before
the notified body numbers uh there could
be also new symbols being used
uh um for example for self-tests
um the unique device identifier being
added
so that will definitely require the
manufacturer to revise
all the labels for their
ce marked products under the ibd
regulation
thank you patreon do you have any final
comments for our audience before we go
today
yes i wish everyone
successful implementation there's a lot
of work to be done by the manufacturers
also by the laboratories and
i wish a good success
goodbye thank you very much
thank you very much for your time today
and for your research
we would also like to thank ravers and
our sponsor molecular diagnostic
at abbott for underwriting today's
educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
any questions we did not have time for
today and those submitted during the
on-demand period
will be addressed by our speaker via the
contact information
you provided at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand and
lab roots will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time goodbye